3 p.m pacific time
[Music]
coming up next on book notes we talk
with shen tong one of the pro-democracy
student leaders involved in the 1989
student protest in beijing china
he is co-author of the book almost a
revolution the story of a chinese
student's journey from boyhood to
leadership in tiananmen square
[Music]
chen tong author of almost a revolution
in the epilogue of your book you write i
believe the end of tyranny is near
how near
well i think
for me for a lot of people they think
the movement in china is over but my by
my definition
when we're talking about poor democracy
movement in china i see more fundamental
as in more fundamental way i mean the
foundation for the last spring movement
the people's dissatisfaction the
decentralizing political and economic
trained by the local government
central government reformers versus
conservatives and also
you know the factions in the army
radical intellectuals searching for the
new possibility for china all these
factors they were foundation for the
last spring movement and they were only
deepened and strengthened by the
massacre itself
so i think the potential is still there
and even stronger and after last spring
movement we have our underground
movement as well as exile movement so i
think the movements still keep going
although we have a surface setback and
we paid a big price last spring
here's the cover of your
book who is this
the the two students stand out uh
actress was standing on a bus trying
during a demonstration you know one of
them
was my
uh friend what's his name
uh
i i don't want to give his name but
he's in
qinghai university
one of the beijing biggest universities
so he's still in china
yeah
when did you leave china
last june
like a week after the massacre
and where are you now i'm in brandes
university in
boston area studying what studying
biology and philosophy and also my group
democracy of china fund also based in
boston group
my
exile pro-democracy movement
organization it's called democracy china
in based in boston
and what are you going to do when you
graduate and you are a senior i'm a
senior yeah i'm applying graduate
schools uh started
to move my academic interest to
political science and international
relations
can you go back to china right now i
don't think so no so do you plan to stay
in the united states yeah i'm considered
the
consider myself as exile that's me you
know i can't go back right now but i
will go back whenever it's possible why
did you decide to write a book
well it's uh
it's very uh complicated when i came out
when i escaped from china i was
traveling around all over the world to
tell the people what's going on there
you know and that's the time i find out
it seems there are two tiananmen squares
one is the one i really experienced you
know their excitement frustration even
infighting which never leave the heart
of a social revolution another is the
one
you know kind of created by the western
media it's all each piece of the second
uh kinemaster is so accurate but as a
whole it's quite
dramatic and isolated kind of stick out
from chinese history people
remember people know tiananmen square
god of democracy student in front of
tanks but they don't know exactly where
the movement came from so they don't
really know where it goes so it seems
for them you know china didn't make it
they were closed and eastern european
made it so that's the time i feel the
urgency to write a book as an insider
not only
of the 1989 movement but as
as
a young people young person grew up in
china for this such a distinguished
decade the so-called open-door policy
ever since the end of
1970s how my generation grew up and how
this new generation is totally basic
totally new ideology shaped
uh the new atmosphere in the society and
finally shaped and triggered the 1989
movement
during
the book we get to know your mother and
father and sister and grandmother
your father died recently where when did
he die and what was it of
he passed away a month after i
escaped from china
and
he was he had a physical disease the
blood sensor but uh leukemia
yeah leukemia and uh
the partial reason he died so fast he he
they did
the disease was found like end of may
and he died like two months later where
he was too depressed in a lot of ways
government put pressure on him and he
was
a communist party member all his life he
was trying to follow so-called party
lines you know it's his new is his whole
life ideology and the guard the the
government asked him to be the spy of
his own son which also he trusts a lot
so it's this whole controversy in his
life you know for a long time especially
during the night 1989 movement he was
very depressed
your mother how is she
she's okay she's still in beijing and
working
in a very big
is a hospital and she's a medical doctor
she's a medical doctor yeah
your sister my sister
as my father same as my father and me
she graduated from peak university which
we're very proud of it of my family and
she was working in a garment consulting
company but after my escape government
put pressures on her and took away her
passport and her work unit gave her a
lot of hard time and now she changed to
a foreign company worked for a foreign
company in beijing
and your grandmother my grandmother it's
uh
she's
she's fine she's 76 years old and she
brought me up and
she's still
healthy but the only thing she really
hope can see me in the near future
and
and
hope i hope i can go back soon to see
her now this is a picture of your
grandmother yes when i was very young
like that's the picture when i was 100
days you know after i was born
you say early in the book that your
grandmother at age three started to
teach you important things what kind of
things did you teach them yeah like like
chinese uh traditional literature the
all the important uh uh works like the
the three kind uh 3 3 kingdom
and
the dreams about
it is several important
traditional literature work
one of the things you keep reading are
references to world figures and some
american figures that you seem to know
about and one of them was rosa parks
how did you know about rosa parks when
you were growing up
not not exactly rosa parks excuse me
it's uh we we know more
about abraham lincoln george washington
and dr king
and uh franklin you know
and as well as uh the important figures
during the second world war it's really
uh due to the so-called open-door policy
in china one uh
since the end of 1970s they don't jump
in after the fall of the mazda dunes
dynasty basically then japanese
government
opened door of china to the world and
western materials as well as western
ideas and influential thinkers and
politicians all kind of russian in china
and my generation as a generation grew
up in this totally new atmosphere not
only western
world stuff but also chinese
intellectuals started to search their
own view at that time that there there
were scar literature
so-called new type poetry as well as pop
music which totally created new kind of
culture at least a pop culture and
we grew up we started to think and grow
up from this new atmosphere the
combination of new chinese liberal
liberal atmosphere combined with western
ideals and western materialists and we
have gradually have this new
ideology you know i would say it's
individualism totally different from the
other generations in china previously
and i believe individualism in a way in
a psychological and cultural way is a
foundation for pluralism eventually now
if you were still in china could you
still read these books
right now it's uh
the control is very tight but there's no
way to just wait out all the western
western stuff as well as i mean the
western
uh ideals and other new values how are
they combined with a native chinese
cultural development so there's no way
for the central government to whip it
out so it's still possible especially
you're not in cities like beijing or
shanghai which control is very tight if
you're out of beijing it's quite free
still where did you learn your english
in china and here yeah every chinese
university student learned like two
years so-called common english education
that's that's a part of the open door
policy which have a great deal of
influence on us and
you know we take
a big advantage from that
you live near tiananmen square
yeah yeah it's like a mile west from
tiananmen square this street my family
house on the side of is called eternal
peace avenue chang avenue and tiananmen
square is kind of in the middle
of the changa avenue explain the kind of
living conditions that you had when you
were growing up
well it's it was really different from
uh so-called american life and it's very
uh it's very crowded it's in in beijing
a lot of families
three generations live in one room you
know and
the materials is very
it's very it's lack of materials for you
know people line up a long line to buy
basic supplies
you know but
you know it's it's different it's very
compared the level of living is much
poorer than american life but most of
time people are happy because it's all
this 10 years open door policy people
really feel the sense of
growing their life is getting better and
better
how many rooms were there in your home
it's uh two rooms very small rooms and
we my family built up another small room
when i grew up you know i have my kind
of half room my own
space
did your parents own that
no no it's owned by the government
how do you get your lodging
i mean in other words how
were they assigned through the party
yeah through a work unit party and you
feel high-ranked officials you'll get a
lot of rooms and if you're just
normal uh clerks workers you know small
or low-rank officials you got very
crowded in your family at what stage in
your life did you know that you were
going to be an activist
uh it's quite uh the idea that the
i mean the kind of shaping period is
ever since when i was very young is from
my family was a very liberal family she
brought me up in a very liberal
atmosphere and i started to involve in
the social activities it's kind of
anti-government activity for democracy
movement ever since when i was 17 years
old in 1985. why were your parents
liberal
well uh there are intellectuals so in
china and in almost every country
they're always kind of pioneers
intellectuals in at least in a
theoretical or spiritual
aspect and also they are very concerned
they concerned the social issue a lot
and they're they were very idealist
idealistic when they were young and
another reason is they graduated from
peak university which is the
political and academic leading place in
china for decades ever since 1919 may
4th movement
and
so that's the
liberal atmosphere i have but there's
always controversy not only in
in particular my family but all my
parenthood and even younger than their
generation but we call cultural
revolution generation like 10 years
older than my generation you know this
fine balance to keep concerned and
unconcerned of the social user keep
concerned mentally intellectually but
keep away from the direct involvement
because they suffered too much their
generation sacrificed too much and
didn't get
anything out of it but both your parents
were members of the communist party
weren't they my father was not my mother
because my mother so
kind of has this
bad family background because one of her
brothers is in taiwan
so there's no way for her to join the
the party although she really
for her whole life almost committed to
the communist party's so-called
communist parties line
have your has your mother or any your
sister been hurt at all because you're
over here and the uh
and the communists obviously know that
you're involved they'll read your book
you worried about that at all well like
what i said after i left china you know
to give my family
some hard time
you know uh unfortunately actually i
would say fortunately my father passed
away if he's still alive since he is
working he was working in the government
he will get a very hard time and my
sister had to change her
her job from a
chinese company to a foreign company in
beijing and they took away her passport
she couldn't travel abroad she was at
one time going to go study in japan yeah
yeah changed her mind or they changed it
for her yes they changed for her they
took away still she's working in a
japanese company and she couldn't go to
japan
even the company wants her to to go to
japan because she they won't give her
passport the chinese government
two of your grandparents committed
suicide
why
uh
it's uh this is not only the part of the
suppression the disaster the communist
party uh created for
for
for 40 years now but also involved in
the chinese old tradition
the the uh matter of faith lose faith
the grace you know they were
viewed you know
wrongly as a so-called rich peasants
although they were very poor my grandpa
was my grandparents were in the
countryside near shanghai
since they have arguments with
the new communist party leader in the
village because they think they're not
they're corrupting they were corrupting
and they are viewed as rich peasant and
during cultural revolution
the uh the red guard want to draw them
to go on
some kind of demonstration you know
criticize them show them to the uh
villagers their their friends so
right before the night they're about to
go on the street they committed suicide
how many of uh people like yourself who
were involved in the tiananmen square
activities are here in the united states
now
there are students
about you know more than 10 of them 20
around but also there are intellectuals
much older than us
older as 60 or 70 years old also exiled
from china and our exile community is a
very big as a student
in this country there are 75 000 chinese
students from mainland china in the
united states and people who are very
active
and very visible take very visible roles
in the exile movement is about 100
hundreds of them
75 000
mainland chinese students in this
country yeah how many of them have come
since tiananmen square uh there are
about seven
of them but not all of them most of them
were not activists in in the movement
because most actives are in jail now in
china can someone living in china who
wants to come out
now and go to school here will the
government allow them to leave almost
impossible there are so many
registrations like you should pay
a lot of fee almost impossible fee for
uh
for chinese family like 10 000 chinese
dollars and
and also you should have direct
relatives overseas which not a lot of
chinese do
so it's they put a lot of registrations
makes it's impossible for students to go
abroad
the uh
it says on the cover this uh shenton uh
with marianne yan
did marian yen actually do the writing
on the book yeah we we wrote it together
and she did a lot of job and she was a
reporter for washington post for five
years and right now she's in columbia
university is she chinese she's a
chinese american
born here
she was born in taiwan an immigrant to
uh to the united states when did you
start working on the book
it's in uh january yeah and past january
and what what's the reason what's the
purpose and what do you hope will happen
with the selling of this book is it do
you make money with it well definitely
there are you know uh learning partner
money part but like that's what i said
that was really you know the time i
really feel i can write this so-called
autobiography as a 21 years old
uh student is i really want the whole
world not only
just remember tiananmen square the
dramatic thing but also understand our
desire for freedom on the face of
chinese future and
you know where the moment are you coming
from are you going to try to get this
book back into china
uh now the english version i'm trying
i'm trying to uh also do the chinese
version and smuggle in china is it
possible to smuggle things back into
china oh yeah definitely that's part of
our exile movement we broadcast back to
china which can reach 80 percent
population every morning and also uh we
smuggled our
overseas
chinese language newspapers and
magazines express our
as exiled movement views and
news about eastern europe and all the
world
events going on and smuggled in china
from from south
from what down south hong kong yeah hong
kong and
macquarie thailand
now um uh you say you broadcast 80
percent of the mainland china we recover
60 of the land but reach 80 percent
population how uh we have uh we made the
tapes in chicago our radio station june
first uh project uh uh june for voice of
june 4th in chicago and we
made the tape there and brought us from
taiwan and several other places around
china in you know in mainland china do
you hear back from people after you do
that oh yeah they read to us all the
time we got you know tens of males every
week
what do they say this i mean first of
all there see it's now
the value about the uncensored uh news
is one part definitely it's valuable
more importantly people feel the strong
hope from the fact we are still have the
voice in china as exile movement and we
are bringing hopes to chinese they
really appreciate this you know our work
and they encourage us to keep up the
work
when you were
living in china and
in high school and in college and the
school you went to was was uh peking
university king university yeah um by
the way how did you get in there
well we we had so-called college
entrance
examination which is very
it's like the sat in this country but
much harder because you know it's very
hard and you must pass that is almost
the only standard for the student to get
in school especially very good school
leading university like peak university
so people spend at least half a year or
even a year somebody do it over and over
again for several times
to take the test
and um that do you have a choice of
where you go to school i mean in other
words you can you can have choice but it
only depends on your your your grade on
that and the so-called big test can you
then choose what you want to study
yeah yes yeah but
when you choose your major it's not like
liberal arts education in this country
when you choose your major in the very
beginning before you enter the
university you should stick to it
basically you can't study i mean i was a
biology major all my classes only
biology
camp chemistry and philosophy you know
you can't easily switch to philosophy
although i'm very interested in and now
here in brandeis i can study both
philosophy and biology
when when you were in school what kind
of things i mean
americans like to think that they spent
millions and millions of dollars to the
voice of america and things like that
influencing people inside china
um
to
stand up and and
you know be for democracy did
did any of that get through oh
definitely the voa
bbc and hong kong newspapers magazine
have very big impact on chinese people
because chinese people view all these
new sources as uncensored the real free
press meanwhile the you know generally
these things chinese press and it is
chinese practice all government control
all should go along with so-called party
lines by the documents sent by the party
although they're also in the in the in
the press in general among journalists
are also reformed for years already
and uh
and
still
voa and bbc and hong kong taiwan
magazines and newspapers still bring
real news and hopes along with our
broadcasting station and newspapers to
chinese people and i i i just hope
voa can do can keep up their good work
and also
make it more freer
news i know
there are a lot of concern about the
chinese government
you know
by the by the broadcasting station i
hope they can really
have a free
position on this issue go back to uh
what would you say was the beginning of
tiananmen square
when when
when did the
activities that you first got involved
in
uh in your opinion lead to what
eventually became the june 4th situation
i think the 1989 movement was explosion
of the
of the whole more than 10 years
contemporary chinese poor democracy
struggle ever since a 1978 democracy war
movement at that time i was very young i
was 10 years old i didn't involve
although that was it's a the democracy
war movement is just like two minutes
walk from my from my house
and that set up that's a milestone for
the uh contemporary chinese struggle for
democracy and it really set up the pace
and uh you know gradually started to
do this kind of self-education for the
whole nation for what democracy really
means what pluralism means what the
problem with the system and almost every
year
after that you know there was a elite
and urban area movement gradually become
bigger and bigger till 1989 finally it's
become real nationwide involved all the
classes not only elite not only
intellectuals or students but also
workers
journalists and peasants even you know
the whole nation started in 1989.
i read in your book that
may mispronounce it
spoke to a class or a some kind of an
event at your school
and he was then a member of the
communist party
he was communist party and he was vice
president of a university another major
university in middle china
um
is called university of uh science and
technology
and he was a vice president there and he
uh his he became for years uh the
symbolic uh leaders of of uh radical
intellectuals you know welcome
urging the chinese government opened the
door more and more and welcomed more
western ideas western format of
democracy so he becomes the
the hero and singles in a lot of young
students a chinese student
and he is is he still in cambridge yeah
he yeah he escaped
yeah to cambridge is he coming here he's
coming i believe to princeton next year
have you talked to him since he's been
out uh yeah we contact him and
he is
he's in in the school and doing his
research and meanwhile keep informed of
the
exile movement and he will in his own
way
involved in the humorous struggle for
china but again go back when you were in
school was he one of your heroes when he
came to speak to you did you follow him
after that oh definitely he has a big
impact and not only him their whole
school of uh
you know
and
i would say radical liberal
intellectuals you know gradually grow up
uh in in this open door policy older
intellectuals and they have they all
have a very big impact uh on our
generation on the students on campus
how much were you involved in the actual
tenement square events as a leader and
what was your role
uh you mean the 1989 movement and i was
in charge of a group called the olympic
institute along with several other
groups like campus student group like
democracy salon hired by another student
leader wang dan we started one after
huevan's death started the movement in
in peak university and then in beijing
you call it olympic institute yeah
that's a group i i was ahead of before
the movement started and after movement
started i was in charge of the news
center we have radio station newspaper
as well as we hold a press conference
for western
journalists and
and then
me and another student organized a
dialogue delegation one of the three
student leading groups which our task is
to negotiate maintain the ties with the
government and negotiate holding
dialogues represent the students
until the end
another thing i remember is that winston
lord who is ambassador to china from the
united states spoke to one of your
classes
uh not my class uh the uh the group i
mentioned before democracy salon which
is a group work closely with my olympic
institute they uh they hold open
discussions every wednesday it's also
called wednesday forum and winston lord
as well as
the foundation was there uh spoke to the
students and the government would allow
that
well at that time it's it's always very
tricky in the country with with
dictatorship like china you know when
the atmos general atmosphere is kind of
loose you can do something as
as far as you don't cross seems the
invisible line you don't cross that line
you can do something quite free
but if you crop cross that line you know
which
frightens the government they'll crack
down like what happened in june in 1989
but the lead periods are a very long
lead period before the movement emerged
which we hold
open discussion on campus we contact and
discuss with
social activists as well as radical
intellectuals for a long time and also
we even precisely
planned and prepared for the 1989
movement although the outcome is it's
kind of out of control
there's a lot in this book that we're
not going to be able to talk about but
one thing it's a little bit off the
subject here i read this almost
the last
page of the main book i had never hugged
anyone in my family and uh i didn't do
it then
you write a lot about the lack of
physical
uh
relationships between families no
hugging handholding and things like that
where does that all come from
well definitely
the
custom in china the way chinese
related to each other are
quite different
compared with
americans so we really kind of hold back
as more inside a
nation as a nationality as a whole
and but that's one thing also i think is
changing in my generation we discovered
the freedom of individual we discovered
even the sexual uh
in the sexual freedom in a number of
other ways
here's a picture of you and a girlfriend
by the name of andrea yeah is she still
your girlfriend
yes she she's a brazilian she was my
schoolmate in china and now she's in
wellesley college so she's right up
there near boston oh yeah
and this is a picture of the two of you
holding hands is that something that
how did you learn the uh the personal
affection compared to all the other
people in your country well it's quite
common in my generation although it's
kind of a big surprise for my parenthood
as what i said we really discovered not
only in in a deep philosophical way the
individualism the seeking the hope
inside ourselves questioning the old
culture questioning the government but
meanwhile you know we
we explored you know a lot of new things
which kind of uh you know new very very
new for the older generation in include
the sexual freedom
what do you think of our government
i'm very disappointed and
the exiled moment chinese exile movement
is very disappointing that the george
bush demonstrations and the on their
policy on scene of american relations i
think uh the bush administration is
choosing the wrong side of history in
this issue
by choosing the beijing regime versus
our exile movement our our poor
democracy movement in other words
people's desire in china and i think
you know when i came to this country
people was talk told me and after 1949
there was a phrase in this country said
we lost china
simply referring to the communist party
drove away uh coming down to taiwan
but i think if the bush administration
keep doing what he's doing on the
sino-american relations you know one day
he will say
there will be another phrase where you
lose china again
what do you say to those in china who
might say i'm glad that george bush has
kept the lines of communications open
because if he didn't have a most favored
nations treaty and things like that the
door would be closed and we wouldn't
have any dialogue i agree with that
that's my point of view also the fine
lines the fine balances first of all we
should keep the door open to china
because it's open door policy brought up
all this and the door must be open to
china although the hotliners in beijing
try to shut it down completely but
meanwhile by remaining the relationship
with china trade relations diplomatic
political symbolic relations
the american government and other
governments can do more than cut down
totally the relationship so by granting
the mfn status you can you can do
differently than what john bush
administration has done by putting
conditions you know this country i don't
need to talk about all the techniques
that mr bush knows better than me
your country has done so much to other
countries other issues like south africa
like soviet union so many other examples
but remaining relations you can really
promote in the long run the people's
desire for the democracy for china like
you know the condition can be released
all the political prisoners and there
are thousands of them are in jail if
they're released it's a big it's a big
factor it will be a big factor and
strong impact on the current underground
movement in china you write a lot about
seeing friends of yours or people that
you were in the square with killed right
in front of your eyes
yeah um
during the moscow night yes i was
on the uh
changa avenue the itunes peace avenue a
mile west from the square which was the
most brutal killing field of the
massacre night and
a lot of people are talking about how
many people died
in the square actually it's kind of
misleading by the chinese government
because there were not a lot of people
died right in the square the people who
outside square especially the west part
of city were trying to prevent the
soldiers
martial or soldiers from rushing in the
square and crack down on the
on the
student in the square and it's there a
lot of people were killed and gunned
down by the martial soldiers what's this
picture on top right here that was the
uh
the negotiation with the government one
me and another
co-president of the dialogue delegation
went to the government liaison officer
and after a close door meeting all the
journalists were surrounding us and
asked what happened what's the what's
this picture right here that was a may
4th demonstration that was a anniversary
of a very important
movement in 1919 may 4th movement its
70th anniversary of it when me and wang
another
leader leave the peak universities
demonstration go in the square
when um
when you think back of
the friends you made and all that uh
this is the giant and i know we'll get a
picture here uh where is the giant and
who is he he he is a chinese american he
was my schoolmate uh and a roommate when
i was in peak university and recently he
graduated from peak university and now
in los angeles so he came back to the
states yeah
about this uh
fellow right here uh he was my high
school uh
classmate and uh he's in shanghai still
in university studying was he involved
at all in the
tiananmen square activities
no because he was in shanghai a city in
the middle of
china where was this picture taken it's
in beijing when i i described when i
prepared the big test the college
entrance examination written on the back
wall is smile yeah
yeah it was very tense period for every
student it's like it's like
it's like a horror for everybody so i
just try to let me you know relax
and what's this picture down here it's a
it's a happy period it's after me and my
uh my best friend daquin uh entered the
uh our university and we took the
picture in beijing
what uh
if if you had the government that you
would want what would it look like
well the uh
the final format of the
democratic political structure there are
a lot of format which we can
we can do search on it for china exactly
what china should look like but i think
it's more important now as as a
democracy as a poor democracy movement
in china as a state where are now i
think it's more important to
figure out what kind of ways were taken
in order to get that final democracy i
think china should undergo the uh
several approaches it's a it's a
combination of hungary poland and
czechoslovakia's revolution for years
which i mean the internal reform
and opposition political force as well
as general people's awareness for what
democracy really means people's
recognition people
of of human rights and people's
political awareness
you uh during the tenement square
activities you spent a lot of time with
reporters
and i remember that you you had a
dialogue almost daily with
a couple of hong kong reporters as well
as uh canadian french and american
reporters because from very beginning i
was in charge of the
news center for the whole movement in in
pekka university so we hold press
conference as well as you know the
broadcasting station the radio station
is right in my dorm room and also the
newspapers or the newspaper headquarters
the only independent newspaper run by
students during the movement and you had
a broadcast station that you broadcast
to tiananmen square
uh it's uh it's a it's based in
the peak university so it can basically
reach the so-called university town in
the
one area in beijing which a lot of
universities are there
what impact if any did american
television have on your movement did you
see american television programs at all
no not really we can't really see it but
uh for my case i was uh
the first news about the crackdown
is pre-crackdown in the uh afternoon of
june 3rd i watched it through cnn in
in a
very fancy joint venture hotel in
beijing
and i don't think a lot of people really
watched was the
western media report on the movement
during the movement but they definitely
know there are a lot of reporters so
they know
the movement their struggle they are
holding on uh eyewitnesses are watched
by the whole world that's one that's one
very important difference
the nightingale movement has compared
his previous movement
reading your book you you see that
you're always having disagreements among
the students as to when to pull back and
when to insist on dialogue
you think that if you'd pulled out of
the square before the third and fourth
that you would have could have avoided
the deaths and still made your point
if we hold this theoretical discussion i
think we we would i mean if it left the
square earlier probably we can avoid the
masker itself but i think
a country like china was such a strong
suppression whenever they got in the
mass movement like last spring there's
no way to so-called control
either by government or by so-called
leaders of the movement because it's
just like a broken dike so if if
somebody asked me you know what can i do
differently if i can do it all over
again i think the only thing i can do
differently is the timing the one to
trigger the mass movement so like what i
mentioned before i think china should
undergo the three approaches for enough
time and then we should trigger the next
mass movement like last spring and the
difference will be we can make it inside
of a big price during the massacre night
who's got all the power in china right
now right now the central government is
very powerful uh you know in beijing
they they're trying to control
everything you know like what they did
for for years after 1949 but meanwhile
the decentralizing uh political and
economical training is very strong local
government especially the coastal area
they're getting greater greater power
you know in kind of signing
independently and meanwhile the faction
is in the army is also very strong and
based upon people's dissatisfaction the
central government
power is shaking and all
more importantly after the the first
fire in 10 minutes in beijing they
totally lost their legitimacy among the
chinese people
is there anybody i mean is deng xiaoping
still in power lee pong uh are these
people these people matter anymore oh
they
sure they are very important now in the
chinese politics and they are holding
the power tightly by holding the army at
least trying to hold the army and the
whole country the whole press you know
as much as possible and it's very it's
it's very crucial uh the hotliners like
deng xiaoping or others their death is
very uh crucial for our progress for our
struggle for democracy struggle but on
the other hand a lot of people think
only after they dead we can keep
going our movement which is not true
because they didn't see they see one
hand this very strong factor i agree
with it but meanwhile there are other
factors the local government factor the
free economies uh situation in china
faction into army all these things
meanwhile added to it underground
movement as well as very strong exile
movement all these factors plays an
important role in the chinese right now
the the current
political picture and i think in a way a
lot of people thinking about if you deal
with china's only ways deal with chinese
the beijing government is correct if
china was 20 years ago but it's not
correct now after this more than 10
years open-door policy in 1997 hong kong
reverts to the under the control of
chinese
there are six million people sitting
right on that southern border there
with a lot of private enterprise and a
lot of successful
business and business activity
and what right across the border in
guadalajara there's a lot of
activity also is that southern
attitude going to move up through the
country oh definitely i think
it's unstable a lot of hong kong people
worried of 1997 but i and collectively
when i see the china's picture as a
whole all the problems related to china
i think it's the beijing government
should be frightened by you know taking
back the hong kong because there is a
real free society it will have a great
impact as what
it has already provided for china for
years especially south china and
intellectuals in the coastal area and
it's not only hong kong the problem you
know the issues of taiwan free tibet
movement and others like macau mongolia
all these things all these
issues related to mainland china
politics we all have their own role
important role in the future china's
political struggle do you hope to go
back someday and live in china
definitely yeah as soon as possible
you don't like it here
no i like it a great deal and i i really
learned not only from the school in the
academic world but also learn as a
political activist a great deal from
this country what really democracy means
what you know democracy looks like as a
i i would say institutionalized
democracy society you know democracy not
only the ideal the people's desire for
society guarantee basic human rights and
it's not only uh in the government
structure or free press or the social
balance but democracy become
a sense of citizenship
people's individual involvement you know
uh in the society so i really i i enjoy
my life here
and i'm grateful to this great nation
here's what this book looks like almost
a revolution
shentong is our guest and we're talking
about his activities in relationship
with tiananmen square it's actually a
lot about your life from the early days
uh
ozawa the uh conductor of the boston
symphony orchestra
you know that man i mean you've
you've listened to him play beethoven
and how did that happen well that's part
of the so-called open-door policy when
the uh uh is it's the end of 70s so all
this western culture you know started it
was in china before the cultural
revolution and it's totally shut down
during the 10 years disaster since 1966
to 1976
and there were two years kind of lead
period before the real open door
policies started in 1978 you know all
the western music you know classic as
pop music not only beethoven mozart or
tchaikovsky but also beatles simon
garfunkel and even john danforth was
there and his everybody knows their name
as well as martin luther king or abraham
lincoln's name
who taught you about beethoven mozart
and tchaikovsky well there are
generally all these things are available
were available at in china and i was
studying vowing with my violin teachers
for a while and although i was not
availing a
good violin player my neighbor forced me
to stop
and uh but meanwhile it taught me to
appreciate the
classic music and it's become a very
important part of my life now
was your upbringing and your family even
though you say you lived in what a room
and a half of so is the family
more than two rooms and
um how would how would you describe the
conditions of how you lived compared to
what we have here
well it's really
it's different it's not they're not a
very tall building except the recent
years built a lot of fancy hotels and
tall buildings we were live in in in
just a house it's a flat house without
just one floor connected with other
houses yeah connected with other houses
we have a so-called yard chinese yard
which several families live in the same
yard and they all each share several
rooms you know that
there is it's a traditional chinese yard
you know we believe in that and
and a lot of yards are very good and
good quality house but not my house
and uh
you know
the original question was
uh
your grandmother and your mother and
father and the atmosphere they created
is it much different than it was in a
lot of other chinese families or that
you said there were
intellectuals uh would you have would
you have had a hard time
learning some of the things you did if
it wasn't for the fact that your parents
were intellectuals
yeah correct i uh there is different you
know the my family comparison i mean
it's a basically a
an intellectual
family your mother and father in the
middle here
see and this yeah in the middle yeah
it's my father and mother and it's my
sister on the on the left yeah how did
again how did they become intellectuals
uh my my mother
was
orino was nurse and she kept studying
and become a family become medical
doctor and my father and my sister they
all graduate from
peak university which is a leading
university academically and politically
in china
what do you want to eventually do with
your life
well
now i
consider myself as a
political activist for promote democracy
for future china and i'm very committed
to this to this cause and i think
i believe now i'll spend most of my life
uh stick to this cause you think so
and you said you you started to study
biology
yeah when i was in china for a while
when i was like every tower type student
you know i really believe science can
save china and uh
and i enjoyed a lot by studying biology
and now philosophy but i will study
political science and
international relations for my graduate
study
hopefully next year starting next year
and now i'm deeply involved in the exile
moment how do you afford to live
well i'm
i'm on i'm leaving a scholarship
provided by the brandeis university and
then what happens after that if you're
going to be a political activist for
your family and friends back in china
how are you going to be able to pay the
bills once you get out of school
no i'm trying now i'm i'm deeply
involved in the movement i'm trying to
keep almost impossible you know it's
it's
the campus life as well as
activist life i'm traveling around all
over the world trying to bring people's
awareness
bring up dialogues between the chinese
community to the other
out to other
movement like like civil rights movement
internal labor movement eastern european
democracy movement and hopefully i hope
i can get the scholarship for my
graduate study again and meanwhile i'm
by uh promoting uh
the movement you know we we also raise
money to keep up our
exile movement
when you talk to americans that don't
know china don't understand it what do
you tell them
about the difference in life and the
difference between the freedom that we
have versus what you don't have back
home well it's uh when i went to uh i
went through a lot of i give a lot of
talks and
speeches to americans
to tell them what was going on there oh
i mean one example i use which i think
is very
direct to them you know because this all
this kind of gathering i can tell them
it's not possible in china and even if
it's possible you will always have quite
a few uninvited people among you
listening everything you say and taking
mental notes and you know for sure even
before you go there your name represents
in this uh in in the gathering your name
and even your family names will be on
the government list
that's that's that's the reality in
china it's not imagination this this
kind of suppression is some control
i mean americans a lot of them take the
freedom they have here for granted you
know the election just just passed and a
lot of the voter rate is very low
and they they really
don't know what freedom means if you
don't watch closely you'll lose it again
and i and also in this regard i also
believe like dr king said injustice
anywhere is a threat to justice
everywhere no you can't say you're
afraid one 1.1 billion people in china
are still struggling for basic human
rights and just what they're struggling
for is something you enjoy it so much
here and even take it for granted what
was the hardest thing about writing this
book with mary ann yan what was hard
about it uh it's not really hard in
terms of our collaboration the very hard
part is
the movement belongs to millions of
people you know it's hard for me to try
to write in a kind of historian's view
and also
you know i'm still it's an ongoing uh
struggle i'm still in the story i can't
really have so-called accurate uh not
not necessarily an uh
objective way to write it although i
tried my hard to to write down to record
all the uh things happened minute by
minute but still
you know it's very hard to uh to show
the so-called umbrella picture as a
historian but meanwhile you know by
writing the almost revolution it's
really strengthened my commitment to the
movement because i by reviewing in such
such a systematic way my life and my
generation's life is really encouraged
me to go to keep going on this road and
i felt you know the strong
strength in my inside myself because i
felt the whole my generation the young
generation are still with me keep my
dream alive in the back on page 339 you
list a whole bunch of people and where
they are today
one of the people that was and we only
have a couple minutes that was uh
prominent in the book was chai lang
where is she she right now when i wrote
the book she was in paris and right now
she's in princeton university so she's
here now yeah
how come so many people went to paris
well because the french
government
provides the umbrella
for chinese exiles
and it was much easier than the united
states
easier than coming here because the
chinese government would let you know no
no no when they we all most of us
escaped to hong kong my case was
different i fled out of china and to
japan first and but the rest of us
escaped from
thailand macro or mainland hong kong and
they were waiting there for other
government to provide
refuge and
it's it turned out french government
canadian and australia
especially the french government are the
best so the americans weren't as open as
they should have been in your opinion i
hope they can do better there are still
a lot of
activists escaped to hong kong didn't
settle down yet although american did
sponsor some
refugees here
this is what the book looks like it's
called almost a revolution
and its author and principal
character in the book is shen tong one
of those actively involved in the
democracy movement in china thank you
for joining us thank you
[Music]
next week on book notes we will look at
the politics of the middle east with
authors john and janet wallach their
recent book arafat in the eyes of the
beholder profiles the plo leader and
discusses his role in the organization
and in the ethnic disputes of the region
for a printed transcript of tonight's
program send five dollars to tapewriter
incorporated box 885 lincolnshire
illinois 60069
[Music]
so
[Music]